The games people have a definite constraint. Like if it goes less than 30
frames per second then they have to cut back somehow. They have to get rid of
polygons or they have to go beat their artists to go put you know, less content
in the scene. but since your selling to who knows who, you know, the guy could
say, I wanted 50 oil derricks or, you know, 50 whatevers. You know, in my scene
and so what, what kind of technique are used to sort of control that, so I want
as much as I want, you know.
&gt;&gt; Some of those are sort of reducing geometric complexity, where if you have, you
have a complex model so as you start to orbit if it's too slow, we can desimate
some triangles from that. So again, there, there are a lot of techniques that
are similar between games and CAD in those situations. We tend to let the user
have more control over that, where, again, they, they may care more about it.
Some customers maybe fine you know, if they need to orbit something, we can
turn it into a wireframe object, because that will get them to the point they
need, and then we go back to the, to the full resolution. And lighting is
another one where we can have some effect. We have a landscape lighter who has
a thousand lights in their scene and you can't necessarily do that in real
time. So sometimes we, we'll cut out some of the lights that will have a lesser
effect on the scene. So instead of getting 100% fidelity with the real world,
we, it may only look 80% correct. While they're moving around, but then once
they stop, then we can, we can go back to showing the full scene.